your business generates mountains of
data but are you really taking advantage
of the insights it could reveal
you can use machine learning a branch of
AI to analyze your data and predict
future outcomes or identify hidden
patterns
today I'll cover two approaches namely
supervised and unsupervised machine
learning
the big difference between the two is
how the training data is labeled
as the name suggests supervised learning
needs guidance we do this by using
labeled data sets a label is simply a
known value that we specify on each row
in the data set it could be something as
simple as a binary yes or no
a category or a score
but what if we don't have all the
information needed to assign a helpful
label
well that's when unsupervised learning
comes into play
with this approach we use machine
learning to detect hidden patterns in
data without our help
I think a few examples will help
illustrate the big differences
let's start with supervised machine
learning say we run multiple factories
each with robots that need maintenance
but when exactly
well we know from experience that the
temperature of our robots and the level
of vibration affects their service
schedule so we decide to monitor those
attributes
this table contains the information
we've collected the goal is to get our
model to use the data to predict the
label maintenance needed yes or no
and basically that supervised learning
we provide labeled data and supervised
learning produces a model which can
accurately predict that label now when
the prediction is something like yes or
no maintenance needed or not needed we
call that binary classification
then there's multi-class classification
it's a bit of a tongue twister that
indicates any number of states
so in our robot example a multi-class
classification might indicate if the
robot needs maintenance or not
needs replacement
or just need some rest
in other words the multi-class approach
provides more context using our binary
classification model we were able to
schedule maintenance on Demand by
feeding real-time metrics into our model
and getting a simple yes or no
using the multi-class classification
model we got that and we added whether
we might need a replacement robot or
could just give a robot a break
another popular form of supervised
machine learning is called regression
regression is used when you want to
predict a continuous value like
temperature
back to our Factory
we can train a model to predict what a
robot's temperature should be given how
hot it is in the factory and the robot's
power consumption
with that model we can compare the
predicted temperature to the robot's
actual temperature
unlike our first example where we
predicted maintenance needed or not
with regression we might use a dashboard
to keep an eye on the situation instead
of getting a predictive yes or no okay
now we understand the basics of
supervised machine learning let's take a
look at unsupervised machine learning
remember this is the approach that
learns from a data set without labels
instead we look for patterns in the data
there are three main types of
unsupervised learning the first is
called clustering which groups unlabeled
data based on similar characteristics
for example an online store might use
clustering to develop customer personas
that group people with similar buying
patterns
so how is clustering helpful well take a
look at this data set
even though this is relatively small
it's still hard for the human eye to
detect any patterns
now look at this image we produce with
clustering
in this 3D diagram we've plotted out the
numbers in that table now we can easily
see clusters
or spot any outliers
this has major implications for online
retailers using this model you can
tailor your user experience for each
group you can also flag customer
behavior that doesn't fit any Persona
and could be identity fraud
the next type of unsupervised machine
learning is called Association
Association is used to identify
relationships in the data
picture your music streaming playlist
when your platform pops up a message
listeners who liked X also liked why
that's Association
finally there's dimensionality reduction
it helps eliminate noisy redundant data
from unmanageable data sets
this reduction simplifies the input Data
before training a model it's sort of a
smart tactical way to trim fat and
actually get more accurate results with
less data
okay so that's my brief overview of
supervised versus unsupervised machine
learning but the question remains which
approach is right for you if you want to
predict outcomes and you're willing to
train your model by manually labeling
your data supervised learning is your
best bet
in our Factory example knowing what
robots needed servicing reduce downtime
with proactive and cost-effective
maintenance
but if you have lots of data and are
struggling to identify patterns go with
unsupervised learning it can help clear
the fog that's preventing you from
seeing what the data is telling you in
our simple music shopping example
grouping shared interests helped improve
the customer experience and boosted
sales
when you're ready to start think of it
as an experiment there are many
different tools you can try check out
the links in the description to get
started if you want more information on
machine learning and other technology
topics check out the free resources
available to you on developer.ibm.com
if you like this video and you want to
see more please like And subscribe if
you have any questions drop them in the
comments below